nous revendiquons et nous assumons la
signature toute récente d'un très
important contrat concernant
l'acquisition de 80 avions de combat
rafale par les émirats arabes unis et de
douze hélicoptères caracal il est le
résultat ce contrat d'un partenariat
ancien
matérialisée par des accords de défense
et la présence de base française aux
émirats arabes unis je vous le rappelle
dont une a été récemment encore
indispensable au bon déroulé de
l'opération harpagon
d'évacuation des ressortissants français
européens et des pays tiers ainsi que
des afghanes et afghans menacé du fait
de leurs liens avec la france je
rappelle que ce contrat va également
soutenir plusieurs milliers d'emplois
dans les 400 entreprises françaises qui
travaillent pour le programme rafale et
qu'il fait suite mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs à plusieurs contrats de
vente qui sont venus confirmer
l'excellence de la technologie française
autour du groupe dassault je vous
remercie
[Musique]